good evening ladies and gentlemen i'm
harvey mansfield i have the honor of
introducing tonight's speaker today
universities are sometimes accused in my
view correctly of political correctness
political correctness is in retreat in
society outside the universities but in
universities themselves it continues
with enormous power what is this thing
political correctness it's not something
which is brand new i first heard the
phrase here at harvard back in the mid
80s and yet it's relatively new
political correctness doesn't mean
having a dominant opinion every group
every society has some kind of dominant
opinion the dominant opinion at harvard
now is liberalism but that isn't what
makes Harvard TC I remember when Harvard
was predominantly Republican so it voted
in 1952 the student body of undergrad
was voted for a President Eisenhower I
remember no political correctness
doesn't mean having a dominant opinion
what it means is the requirement of
sensitivity you must be sensitive to
certain groups anticipate their
objections share their feelings it's not
a question of answering their arguments
rather of making sure that nobody has to
make any arguments political correctness
is more a matter of good manners than
correct opinions good manners means
sensitive manners not forcing anyone to
state an opinion universities today are
correct characterized above all by their
blandness look at the presidents and the
deans
they're mechanical smiles which in the
presence of donors become all-consuming
grins they write soupy prose and they
drink tomato juice and they are
non-judgmental as their highest ideal
they have replaced Plato's idea of the
good with plot skins idea of the vapid
and what about the professor's almost
totally without character obsequious to
students even to parents of students
they're given to grade inflation always
on their knees they are trying to be
with it and failing pitifully professors
are insincere because they try to
repress their true reactions or they're
weak because they have no true reactions
in some they are timid tolerant and nice
we need an antidote to this disgusting
situation tonight's event is sponsored
by the Institute of Politics at the
Kennedy School and by the program
unconstitutional government in the great
great great great grey-green government
department and we set out on a search to
find the most insensitive person in
America
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not in the world but the search was
over before it started because we always
knew that it was Camille Paglia
a woman of character truthful character
shining character pungent character she
can smile and she can bite
she has a few sharp edges
she's a sworn enemy as I've said before
of the namby-pamby the hoity-toity and
the artsy fartsy her opinions are
convincing because they come with
conviction and arguments and they're
appealing because they're non conformist
Camille Palio's professor of humanities
at the University of Arts in the great
city of Philadelphia she received her
bachelor's degree from the State
University of New York at Binghamton and
then condescended to take her master's
degree in PhD in English from Yale she's
a columnist presently for the internet
magazine salon and the author of three
wonderful books sexual persona art and
decadence from Nefertiti to Emily Emily
Dickinson 1990 sex art and Martin and
American culture 1992 and vamps and
tramps 1994 and her latest book as a
study of Alfred Hitchcock's movie the
birds which was published last summer by
the British Film Institute in its film
classics series her topic tonight is the
reform of American education and ladies
and gentlemen it's my pleasure to give
you now Camille Paglia
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening I'm going to talk to about
my philosophy of educational reform
tonight and I this is actually the
number one issue of my career people
have sort of focused in obsessively on
certain controversial aspects of my
feminist philosophy but overall I
consider it my mission to try to reform
both primary and secondary education in
the United States I myself feel I had a
superb education in the public schools
and then at the State University of New
York at Binghamton I'm an enormous a
believer in public education I think
that we've lost the will to keep up the
old standards for many reasons in the
last 30 years if I were to say what is
the purpose of education it is to
sustain I think what is the best
sustenance that we can give to students
that will be of use to them in the long
run looking at the many phases of the
lines I think of this sustenance as of
applying not just to the individual but
to this is not society at large
it shouldn't they should be obvious to
all of us that there is a major
political crisis in in Washington that
there has been a major failure by my
generation of the 1960s in governance
the but the Democratic and the
Republican parties are in disarray we
should be concerned about what kind of
political leaders we are going to have
as we move into the millennium we have
to begin seems to me at the very bottom
level and really look at the kind of
education that's being given I feel that
that too much of contemporary education
about the primary and secondary level is
shot through with a kind of with
negativity with false shallow ironies
with paranoia about the past there has
been
a phone away of the will to give a basic
education to to the students the schools
have become instruments of social
engineering there are a million
political points to the way curricula
structured at both the primary and the
secondary level
now I must emphasize that I am coming
out of the immigrant experience and my
premises remain that all four of my
grandparents were born in Italy and so
with my mother public education was
wonderful for us in America and for a
very long time there was a sense that
primary education should be disciplined
should be orderly should be simple
should unify and for some reason again
many of the forces that were unleashed
by my generation into into the culture
have have have undone that kind of
resolution that we had before let me
tell you a story about my experience
last week I was in New York City and
within the space of two hours I had
where I feel were profound artistic
experiences by visiting three different
buildings the first was Grand Central
Station which has recently been
renovated that magnificent building with
its statues on the front of Mercury the
god of Commerce looking down upon campus
New York the building in the great Bose
art style drawing on elements of Greek
and Roman architecture as filtered
through French culture I walked into
that interior space the beautiful gold
marble gleaming the magnificent ceiling
restored the blue sky and the
constellations of women coming down to
us was that map of the heavens from
antiquity from Babylon and then through
Greece and Rome and I saw all of the
elements of Roman engineering and
background of my own people okay in the
grand arches of the concourse and
thought this is a magnificent public
space a sense of grandeur and Majesty
that speaks for the city and it shows
something about New York's reviving
itself that that that building has been
treated with respect and then I walk
down from there to a few blocks away st.
Patrick's Cathedral now I am an atheist
and I was raised Catholic
I was overwhelmed with a sense of
emotions by the magnificence of that
building the building was jammed with
people from all over the world I must
have heard
15 different languages people were there
with their children the noon mass was
just coming coming to an end there was
such a sense of dignity and spirituality
in that building I did a full tour of
the edges looking at each of the various
shrines each one done in a different
artistic style from Renaissance to to
modernism and there was such a sense of
unity of a global awareness in that in
that building and then without on to the
street and look at the Magnificent
bronze doors I thought this is this is a
fact this is fantastic the symbol the
iconography of Catholicism the the
ability to read the building to
understand the symbolism of the
stained-glass windows and to recognize
the various types aisles of art that I
saw in it that came from my public
education my public school education and
my state university education and I
thought again my sense that there's
something wrong with the way education
is being conducted in the elite schools
when feeling for reverence the feeling
for grandeur has been stripped away from
the students and instead there's a kind
of negativity in a carping toward toward
religion and toward toward belief a
belief is somehow considered ignorant or
reactionary
and then I went on from there to the
real goal of my of my walk the Museum of
Modern Art which has just opened a
Jackson Pollock retrospective the first
and something like thirty years in this
to the museum was jammed with people
many many different languages and
multiple generations people with
children people with children were all
from abroad
the people were children French and
Spanish taking their children to see the
art I didn't see I heard some hearts are
hardly any Americans with our children
and the feeling once again of being
almost is in a church and this was not
not only the works of Pollock a great
avant-garde figure who who literally
shed his own blood no hay for across
tile that was not successful for most of
his career this feeling of being in a
church was was reinforced by seeing like
a shrine a reconstruction of his actual
barn studio in the Museum of Modern Art
done with aged lumber brought from some
of some barns they found some place and
you when walked in it without kind of
hush to see the space the windows the
the roof beams everything about once
again the feeling of reverence for art
and honor of the artist that's not what
you're getting on the elite college
campuses these days
and it hasn't been for the last thirty
years not for its in see a period of so
structuralism and post-modernism where
there is a political ideology to to the
artistic experience where the student
and teacher are expected to hold the red
pen in hand to go down the margin of a
book going check racism check sexism
homophobia finding all the things wrong
with the artwork there's no longer a
sense of the heroic it could be that my
feeling of reverence for art is coming
from being Italian I know it is because
in Italy you don't have these these
ridiculous ideas that high art belongs
to an elite and somehow hoisted on the
lower classes on the contrary in Italy
the great art belongs to the people and
understood by the person who is plowing
the field that the operas belong to
to him that Michelangelo Sistine
Chapel's can belong belongs to him
etc so we don't have this these all of
these to me very pernicious and
moralistic theories about art that have
seeped into American higher education
from the German and French schools and
have been really they work best with a
text on the page they have very little
to do with sensory experiences in the
visual arts those of painting sculpture
dance opera and and so on any rate
having visited those three buildings in
such a short space of time again I
thought I want a primary and a secondary
education that will prepare our students
to be able to have the kind of
experience that I had on that day to be
able to understand the history and in
the design of those buildings you feel
at one with the people in them say not a
sense of false superiority that I'm
afraid that students in the elite
schools are trained to have a
superiority somehow they alone have been
shown the way by Foucault Foucault has
shown them the way they alone okay
are not victim of any ideology everyone
else the hoi polloi out there and you
know and it kind of this meandering
attitude of fall superiority that people
get who have been forced to read like
Andheri Dan Foucault but it is pointless
for me to continue to belabor Lacan and
Derrida who are quite dead
and it's only Foucault that I am
continuing my attack on so I feel that
education is about meaning you give the
students meaning and you help to
organize meaning for them in other words
my philosophy is the exact opposite of
that of the elite professors including
those in the humanities departments at
Harvard they believe it's their mission
to disabuse students of any premises or
assumptions they might have and we're
going to destroy their ability to find
meaning in anything everything is
meaning less when you get done with it
and the great porridge of
post-structuralism now that may have
been appropriate style in the night
60s when you were dealing with 1950s
wasp conformism of the Republican era in
America but the idea that students of
the 1980s or 90s require of their
beliefs to be deconstructed by the
professor it is absolute folly because
the students are coming to college with
nothing they have nothing they need
something is the teachers function to
give the something okay the problem is
I'm afraid that the elite school
professors are very much removed from
the realities of American life they talk
only to each other and then they have a
course a conference circuit of other
like-minded people at Duke Berkeley and
so on and they they're on this endless
kind of funhouse ride of only seeing
their images of themselves everywhere
they never listen to anything beyond
their own immediate circle I myself
because of the disaster of my career
have had a wide range of occasion
experiences I am much more in tune with
America I tried to in fact make efforts
to remain outside of every coterie every
clique I try to be surrounded with
people who would disagree with me at all
times
I had an enormous range of teaching
experiences from I have taught and you
know as a as an adjunct faculty of
visiting Wetterling in the Ivy League
but I've taught in art schools and I've
taught in factories I've taught a
working class students so I'm probably
the only one of my competitors now in
the in the culture wars in the
humanities faculties was actually been
in a factory okay and know what the what
the adult students of mixed race would
like to hear they simply don't want to
hear about the sufferings of watermelon
peasants they want to read Shakespeare
they want to hear about Sophocles they
are taking they're having taking a
course when in their busy family work
lives because they want high art to be
open to them yes high art I believe in
aesthetics in aesthetics no longer
exists oh there are some philosophy
courses that may teach aesthetics in a
very dry way yes i but the aesthetic
in any any reference to the aesthetics
is automatically considered to be
somehow a tool of ideology
now slowly but surely thanks to me the
subject of beauty is back on the agenda
i-i-i-i've enforcing that issue on my
first success was in regard to the
fashion magazines it slowly
I pushed laconian feminism into the
grave ok the anti fashion bias from
laconian feminism and now a new
generation of young women has risen up
who don't find it unconsented wear
lipstick and mesh stockings and and you
know and also be interested in feminism
there was a time when well there was a
requirement of godliness of course in
the 70s and 80s and that was the great
period of Catherine MacKinnon and Andrea
Dworkin but now in the 1990s the reform
wing of feminism which I'm one of the
figures has made an enormous upsurge
it's very clear that we have the
momentum people are no longer willing to
have you know use ideology to to to
dictate to their relationships sexual
relationships or otherwise and in the
fashion is back and beauty the sense of
beauty has reemerged
as a subject of study I myself never
lost that partly from being Italian but
also from my my influence by Oscar Wilde
and Walter Pater Gautier in both lair
I'm very much in the tradition of the
art for art's sake movement at any rate
I feel that there has been too much
ignoring on the part of the king of the
professors of Italy school of the public
education I think there has been utterly
irresponsible the deafening silence on
the part of the humanities faculties
about what was going wrong with public
education in the last 30 years it's an
absolute disaster if you teach in only
school your students are all going to be
very polished no matter where they come
from
they've won the sweepstakes okay to get
into the into the school they all will
have a pretty advanced
a sense of how to read it right and to
produce essays so I think that the elite
school faculties have now realized
extent to which reading is dying it's
that it is dying
the book is dying even while the
bookstores are thriving and the online
book ordering services are thriving
because of the students I have had in
the in the in my long it'll start career
I have I have felt what has gone wrong
in the high schools and I have made a
point to teaching freshman for most of
my career in order to feel that I feel
you know with the freshmen coming into
your class classes are so unformed you
really can see what's what's missing
there is a disaster going on I think a
cultural disaster because of the
failures in primary education the most
important issue is certainly that of
history we we can't have an electorate
which is as ill educated about history
as this one is the sense of chronology
is completely gone in fact the sense of
chronology is complete miss inform the
humanities faculties two of the LC the
Ivy League I mean something that calls
itself New Historicism for example is
one of the worst offenders I'm an old
historicist I believe that art must must
be understood in its historical context
and that's what I have done in my own
work I think that the last person who
was able to to join a Marxist
perspective to to authentic aesthetic
analysis of the history of culture was
Arnold Hauser in his great social
history of art that was produced you
know with relation of four volumes
paperback when I devoured it in in
graduate school I think that was a truly
learned man he shows what how it's
possible indeed to to keep everything
going when you're discussing an artwork
New Historicism
I think is as a disaster the disaster
for to those who practice it the
disaster to those who read it I
encounter in the real world the products
of Ivy League education
I I can see the books coming out from
ideally graduates of particularly the
women who have been touched by the women
Studies programs or and so on they're at
absolute mess historically the sense of
chronology is completely gone
there is people have a frame of
consciousness that's about thirty years
long now my sense of time is coming from
my childhood passion for archaeology I
feel that in my experience of
experimenting with archaeology in the
classroom I feel that our the
archaeology is a splendid tool for both
in both the primary level and secondary
level to help give students that sense
of history that is so missing
archaeology it is the enormous sweep of
time in it and also the sense of the of
the fragility of human institutions and
of the arrogance of power and of Empires
and how quickly they can fall to pieces
the examples of Egypt and Rome are great
examples of it the the enormous sweep of
archaeology the way you're thinking in
thousand year cycles like geology also
which is my favorite science a very long
time frame and possibly I have that time
frame in terms of the sciences - from
being raised in upstate New York which
was sculpted by the glacier of the last
ice age which went through and has left
so many marks in upstate New York that
to travel through to go from Endicott
and Binghamton to to Syracuse is to
follow the path of geological events
that occurred ten thousand years ago
Niagara Falls for example that great one
of the wonders of the world is a remnant
of the last ice age and very near where
my family lives in Syracuse New York is
a dry escarpment bigger inside that
bigger than the Niagara Falls that was
another such waterfall and nothing
remains at all the little glacial pool
bottomless / you know and so on now the
grandeur in the sense of majesty that
you get from contemplate
nature is also something very very
important to me to develop students
sensibilities that also is gone from the
humanities programs of the elite schools
how did that happen
my generation of the 1960's is exactly
the one that gave birth to the
environmental movement how did it happen
that nature could be so totally edited
out of the discourse of post
structuralism and post modernism right
so that you meet I meet these these
products of Harvard or Berkeley or Duke
whose minds are so narrow they are so
small because they've read nothing but
but Foucault and other you know in the
contemporary critics who are imitating
Foucault and so on
so small and their minds so impoverished
in their imaginations they have no
feeling for nature whatever they're
blind a little blind knowns now even if
you respect the code which I do not
because I don't believe that he was was
as learning as people think he was you
respect him all the Foucault ever dealt
with what society okay in society is a
very tiny part of the full spectrum of
the universe human society is tiny
isn't it obvious when you turn on the
television all it needs is one big
hurricane to smash everything that
civilization nature is enormous and
fascinating it's huge it gives you a
sense of the metaphysical whether you
believe in God I believe in nature the
power of nature that is another thing we
have to give to our students okay a
sense of all what what the poet used to
call of the article the sublime a sense
of the sublime if you're not giving that
to your students if you're shutting them
down and making them focus narrowly on a
little tiny fourth ray contemporary
critics you call that education okay
that is an atrocity what you're doing is
you're stealing stealing vision from the
students you're crippling them crippling
them they will knit their inner
creativity will never develop and that's
what's been done two to two generations
now graduate students they may not
realize it but that's been what's been
done to them their original voices
have been taken away from them I just
thank God for the education that I got I
thank God for the old-style public
school education that believed in
history believed in drilling you in with
timelines okay I drill due to diagram
sentences show you the structure of
things okay
gave you a sense of the importance of
politics inspired you with examples of
heroism from the past it wasn't just
everybody was a rogue oh this is the
famous person was a row guess what you
know he beat his servants it wasn't like
that at all okay it gave you a sense of
the of you know of achievement something
to aspire to if we don't help our young
students to dream and to aspire to
greatness if you believe that even
greatness is like is like is like a
rhetorical game being played by
heterosexist a leader sitting in a room
someplace okay now what what are we
doing the whole point of Education is to
open up the world of greatness it seems
to me to the students greatness and
politics greatness and science greatness
and the arts now science my god the way
science has been demeaned by the
humanities faculties of the elite
schools it is evil what has been done a
science for example the way Women's
Studies was put together and now of
course it's involving the general
studying with with science absent
science was considered the the enemy
this is how I got in fact got drummed
out of the women's movement there were
two major quarrel I had with the women's
movement and no discussion was tolerated
I was driven right out of it two
arguments one was about popular culture
my love of the Rolling Stones I was
driven right out that Rolling Stones
were a sexist that was not to be
detailed I was 1969 all right and then
1974 over science when the founding
members of the Women's Studies program
at the State University of New York at
Albany said that science was all
brainwashing and we had that hormones
didn't exist so
and then you know I had been fooled I
had been hoodwinked you not to be there
and so here's appears how Women's
Studies and Gender Studies went down the
wrong road and then it was reinforced by
the anti science bias of post
structuralism later on science should
have been made the keystone of Gender
Studies first of all no one should be
credentialed at all to be discussing a
gender in a college classroom who has
not made the requisite study of science
now I'm not saying you have to be a
biological determinist I'm just saying
that if you're going to be a social
construction construction else you
better have studied endocrinology and
evolutionary biology and you better know
your way around science it is a mockery
of scholarship the way the Women's
Studies programs were put together and
it's going it's going
on and on and on this is the leading
gender theorists our rabid social
constructionist I happen to know the
educational backgrounds of several
bleeding ones of them I can assure you
it's pathetic
it's absolutely pathetic we have these
minor contemporary figures who are being
packaged by PR and being paid enormous
embezzlement level sums okay salaries by
the by the major institutions are and
are being forced upon our students and
using up their precious College time
when the whole point of primary and
secondary education this point should be
about taking students into the great
past
all right the students are already
immersed in the present the present is
around them they are the mass media is
their world now I am a great supporter
of pop I'm a Warhol light the domination
of media in you know with the young
happened to my generation I love
television and advertising Hollywood
movies and so I feel quite at home with
that on the other hand I had the
advantage of this very very strict
old-style public school education
therefore I have a sense of chronology
and history and I can play with one side
of my mind with pop now we have two
generations of young people whose world
has been nothing
but pop nothing but pop and then they
get to Harvard or they get to any of the
other elite schools and they are being
encouraged to play post modernist games
without cutting out sort of things and
juxtaposing them and making and and the
kind of tone that you're supposed to use
of course with all this is like a kind
of cool whimsy and irony and aren't ice
clever and punning and so on and all
that and it just completely cut off at
the neck and again this kind of shallow
irony being imposed on young people when
they should be at their most passionate
all right and when they should be being
developed emotionally it is atrocious
what's being done it's a form of child
abuse okay
post-structuralism should be denounced
all right for it's a child abuse okay
all right now let me go on to a more
controversial matters my my in terms of
primary education now the for the is
obvious that the ideal of universal
literacy is fairly recent it's really a
dream of the American democracy so this
is something that we're still trying to
hash out what what should education be
for the it's obvious that public school
education for the immigrants intimate
long period was a door into American
society and I look back at that period
as in with some nostalgia there were
problems with it certainly but at the
same time it seems to have produced
discipline minds in the young people who
went through that system in upstate in
New York State where I was I was raised
the we had standardized state
requirements the Regents exams they're
like these enormous vampire bats sort of
hanging over the teachers and I never
understood it at the time but the
teachers are always saying that the
region's exam is coming reason exam and
there was always this sense that the
teachers knew that their own
productivity was going to be judged by
the schools in terms of how their
students did on those exams now I think
that that was a good idea
I think we have to really we have to
look again at standardized tests whether
national standards will be intrusive
into states rights as an issue I think
that needs full exploration but the idea
that we should not have tests and that
teachers should not be judged by their
ability to you know to pass their
students along to the next grade is
ludicrous
part of the problem is that the old
public schools drew on woman power in a
period when women had no other options
available to them women could not rise
in the managerial class in in the in
corporate America or in the political
world and so there were incredibly
talented women often unmarried okay who
made school teaching their careers so
that was one thing that's that's gone
now alright those women have gone on to
to achieve you know power in the world
but I remember the devotion and the
labor of those women and the strictness
that they had that's another thing the
strictness in the classroom which is
which which very shortly because of my
generation of the 1960s became
unfashionable by the 1970s when I had my
first job at Bennington College it was
this aisle was that people call you by
your first name the teacher use or
kickback as kind of seminar situation
everything should be go with the flow
etc etc that was a noble experiment in
its own way okay the idea that the
students would be motivated on their own
to find knowledge that after all analogy
you know education is not about really
inserting facts into people's heads
about finding the way to approach life
in time that was a disaster
okay let's face it that was a total flop
okay the oh it might produce a it's a
good way to produce artists okay I think
that people who are intending to go on
in the art world and want to live you
know they basically impoverished life of
rejection okay that's that's a good way
to do it
for the grass majority of students all
right what I have seen is decade by
decade a terrible decline in the
knowledge of young people of the
simplest things you know it's like a
joke on the Leno and Letterman shows for
having sex a joke how little
no on the street now when I travel
abroad I'm even more struck because when
I go to now England has many problems
that have to do with class I certainly
don't want to present the English the
British educational system as any kind
of a model but I'm often struck by the
year the graduates of Oxford and
Cambridge that I need in my in my
travels I'm amazed how much more
sophisticated and cosmopolitan they are
than the graduates of a humanities
program of Harvard and Yale and Berkeley
and Duke right now they're way way more
worldly and they're in their sense of
history is much sharper we are
geographically so isolated here in
America that we must seems to me takes a
group takes special care to make sure
that our students have a sense of the
world stage and I think international
politics is extremely important issue
that must be stressed at the primary
level before we even get to the to the
college level this is going to be a
disaster again for this nation
politically if our students don't have a
sense of what is happening in the wider
world I think that you can tell just by
listening to the BBC news
okay the BBC News Service the radio news
how much broader the consciousness is of
people who live in other parts of the
world we are and of course we are the
joke of the world without all absorption
in these scandals of this year ignoring
every kind of complex developing
political problem abroad so I feel that
our very primary level of school we have
to say our students are going to be
citizens of the world and every single
student there we must prepare okay for
taking place in that wider world such as
our political leaders we must prepare
but the electorate because we've seen
time and time again in history how a
culture that seems to attain power of
quickly disintegrated next I think that
we furnish to to the most economically
disadvantaged in our society at the
public school level we have got to start
stressing business ok small business
management Minh information about bank
and the stock market all kinds of things
that come to members of the middle class
upper middle class from their families
but that people of the working class and
lower middle class do not have any
direct contact with all right we have
got to start looking at primary
education as partly at least vocational
it seems to me sustenance which again
education should be all about is both
spiritual and material I feel that our
education right now is failing on both
grounds material we have to prepare them
people to be able to make a living make
a living in the world where where you do
not have necessarily as in the old days
a lifetime job where companies are
suddenly absorbed into larger
corporation in which you have to may
have to make a number of vocational
changes over the space of your lifetime
so the vocational aspect of primary
education that wood has been really
abandoned I think has to be recovered
there was a time when I was young and
used to seem oh just so terribly sort of
corny once and now looking back at it
again with some nostalgia it was a
period where there was in Syracuse New
York for example the vocational or
technical high school where students who
are not going to go on to college went
to get actual training and skills now
that should be an option to people who
to members of the working class or lower
middle class they they're the tax
dollars their parents pay should be
routed to that kind of vocational
training it's absurd to have our
education only tracking people for some
some college experience that is not even
educational or substance evidence in its
own way and then it throws young people
out in the world with without values
without without facts you know what I
don't anything so they look the
vocational opportunities you know and
you know I think it's an issue that
needs to be brought back to the the
primary school level so I feel that you
know economics and and business skills
are very important what's happened you
all know to the inner cities of is the
with the flight of the middle class to
the suburbs with the the transition from
the menu
actually economy that existed up into
the end of World War two to the service
sector coming of today that we have more
more isolated mass of young people in
the inner cities who not only are
unemployed but have no contact with
whatever with people who are actually
going to work they don't understand the
the the evenness structure of going to
work getting ready for work and that in
that and the way you present yourself
even for a job interview I mean it is
really a disaster what happens in many
parts of Denison again all these
problems have been neglected by the by
the insular elite schools with all their
talk of racial tolerance and racial
understanding and so on and point of
fact their obliviousness to the social
facts of what you know of things
degenerating in the inner cities it's
absolutely shocking the the public
schools have physically degenerated in
the inner cities is disgusting what
would they look like the overcrowding
the lack of resources the the lack of
discipline the dangers and so on I that
to me that the true affirmative action
is where the resources of a society are
devoted to strong public education
especially in these in these inner
cities with there's so many other social
problems where which are overrun by
drugs and every kind of danger I'm very
aware of these things because I teach in
downtown Philadelphia and my school
University of the art is on the very
borderline of what is it's an avenue
that's being created into an avenue of
the arts by by our mayor mayor ndele but
it's right on the borderline of decaying
parts of the city aware it's impossible
to ignore the lack of opportunities of
these these young people and I myself in
my experience the last fourteen years at
this at this university have had contact
with many talented african-american
dancers and actors and so on would
tremendous artistic possibilities is on
and I have I have seen in my own
classroom okay well how they have been
defrauded of an adequate public school
education it is shocking okay what has
been taken away from them that was given
to the immigrant generations of my
mother's you
and also of my era okay so I was so
hopeful that the Clinton presidency
would solve these problems indeed I
think you know Clinton has been a for
all the chaos in the White House
Clinton has brought the attention back
to education but he has not his
administration being distracted by other
matters has not done the kind of work
that needs to be done it seems to me a
social mission for everyone of the
utmost urgency okay there we have
abandoned several generations of
inner-city youth to these these
cesspools of those schools it is
appalling at any rate I believe also
that all kinds of social engineering
ideas that seemed good on the surface
were disastrous for American education
busing for example which looked good on
the on the surface and may have been
positive in a few few examples I think
tore apart too many communities wasted
resources on buses that should have been
spent on the schools themselves I think
our infatuation with that particular
strategy is waning also for the moment I
came on the public scene spoke against
bilingual education that is I feel that
you know the my my mother often says
when she came over here at the age of
six if there had been bilingual
education for Italians she would have
been routed into an Italian speaking
class and would have lost the total
immersion in English which she got
instituted my mother speaks without an
accent got a shred school and so on and
I and look her daughter is no writing
book is writing English you know in all
the ISM you see English is a very very
difficult language when was difficult in
the world the very complex language was
not with many levels because of a
history of of English the you know most
of the most noteworthy example of that
being the the fusion of the Anglo Saxon
monosyllables with the poly syllable
syllables from Greek and Latin that came
in with the Norman invasion so what we
have in English is multiple levels of
diction we might have two three four
possibilities of words
roughly the same thing for a given
context and there's only one way you can
ever master English that's by immersion
in English right and what what people
talk about bilingual education oh it's
fine the kids pick it up
oh they speak English fine sure they
speak English fine for what level of
work for what level of job as you move
along up the ladder until finally you're
arguing a case before the Supreme Court
and under pressure okay
that's when you need this kind of
pinpoint sense of the diction level of a
particular word I hear addiction errors
all the time in fact even native
speakers of English because of the lack
of stress on Basics in basic grammar in
the primary schools and secondary
education are - are getting into the
media where I encountered them - my my
extreme displeasure when they're working
as copy editors on my articles let's say
even at places like the New York Times
this is why I know ok that a Harvard
education may look very pretty on the
outside but it is as a what is Sybil
Kerr all right let me tell you to quote
the Bible I cannot believe are the
number of elite school graduates I have
had to deal with or continue to my pain
at major places of the Republic all kind
of like people who introduce grammars
introduced grammar errors into my
articles but they they don't have the
simple mastery of English grammar why
how have these people managed to go
through sometimes prep school education
as law and go through the elite schools
and get jobs as copiers this is the best
of the law and this is and just the fog
enos and the inability to write simple
paragraphs and the lack of structure in
the back there's something terribly
wrong with with our educational system
and it's no good going on saying oh no
everything's fabulous
it isn't fabulous it's awful alright in
the district the recent graduates I meet
also of the humanities program are their
cows okay in some strange way by their
by their encounters with the tar-baby of
post-structuralism okay which is stuck
to them
they're cloud and they're theirs they're
nice but they're melancholy
okay and they're afraid and they lack
sort of the big zubrin's vitality of my
generation okay who it was were trained
in the with great works of art okay
which which enlarged us great works of
our enlarge the soul they enlarge you
the enlarger imagination and and nothing
great will ever be produced by people
who are told that greatness doesn't
exist okay if you're told that greatness
is just you know IDIA logical conspiracy
then you're never going to be inspired
to spend 20 years of your life writing a
7-hour Facebook the way I did okay all
right I I as a woman was trying to
achieve something great okay I saw it's
about time women do something great like
that okay all right about time something
big something monumental write a book
that goes from kvar to the Rolling Stone
that was my dream okay and so on you
must be must be seems to me fire up
students okay not for all the cold Boosh
of irony on them from a truly okay now
I'm still in primary education here I'm
gonna bet yet alright okay um now I
believe this is very unfashionable I
believe in facts I believe there are
facts every fact is certainly always in
question okay we should you know be
prepared to revise the facts as we
understand them but there are facts not
everything is relative for heaven's
sakes okay I believe there are certain
key facts that people should know and
that it is teachers responsibility to
decide what that core curriculum of
facts should be teachers have had no
guts they're gutless wonders i it is
something skaffa tyria curriculum that
has spread since the 1960s it's absolute
disaster i have a little bit of this and
a little bit a sort of a salad bar thing
a little bit a little bit of that a
little of that okay and resolve nothing
okay end result big 0 now I've noticed
how often people who understand my work
for example which is very historical and
has a strong big narrative sweep to it
which people have with other other you
know post modernists say can't you can't
that can't exist no great narratives are
possible anymore really okay look I can
think in these long there
I've noticed how often that the only
people who understand my work of the
things are often graduate of Columbia
the Columbia program in the history of
ideas I which train very high-level
history buddies in the University of
Chicago also had a very similar sense I
think today I believe the core
curriculum where you determine what oh
who are the greatest thinkers who are
the greatest artists and present those
to the students in a chronological way
to give people a sense of history ok and
so on that is all over the map and kind
of chic juxtaposition or collage ok that
is the proper way to teach now I mean I
believe in Canon revision for heaven's
sake I don't believe the Canon is
something immutable in my own work I I
for example throughout Chaucer and
Milton and I put in the Marquis de Sade
now that was you know I I know that we
are always revising our idea of what is
great that's that should be obvious at
the same time you know there are there
are certain key texts which all educated
people should know and in my work also I
have argue that we do need to expand the
curriculum outward to in a in a
scholarly multiculturalism that includes
all of the great world traditions and I
was the first to argue that that world
religions should be the basis of such a
curriculum and now that idea has been
taken from me I won't mention my home by
people without credit of course at the
time I was I was scoring for that
religion we don't want education of an
indubitable religions but now here at
the end of this decade is starting to
seem more and more attractive because
for me the great world religions include
architecture and in art and and the the
great texts of any given we can't
understand any culture - we know the
religious background of that culture and
I believe that a theist that the world
religions are great symbol systems that
give you a sense of vastness and mystery
of the universe and they are far more
sustaining spiritual aid to students
than Foucault or hang Foucault is a dead
end I keep telling you this and I want
you to go out there and tell everyone
else - I'm a vampire
alright now one of the reasons I love
archaeology has something to introduce
to the students at the primary level of
education -
because it is a wonderful way to show
the scientific method in operation the
scientific method which is again is
score and okay by the post modernist the
archaeology is far more sophisticated
system than post structuralism of
heavens thank you each archaeology there
are these fragments of evidence which
you collect and you catalog and you try
to make sense out of write and slowly as
you gather more evidence about a culture
over years and decades or a century okay
you are constantly revising your
hypotheses about those cultures okay and
so in that the whole process of an
enormous amount of fact and if material
objects treated with such care and
reverence it's not the period of
brigandage and of looting there have
been such so you know such mishandling
obviously of archaeological sites in the
past but that is not the majority at all
of you know of the archaeologists who
have who have devoted their lives is
back-breaking work of collecting all of
this up it's a product by the way of the
Western enlightenment so maligned by
Foucault archaeal modern archaeology is
this great system that was slowly
developed after the Enlightenment and
that is then it was my original dream to
be in archaeology I haven't I know a lot
about it and I am enormously impressed
with it again far more complex a system
okay
the way you you have a few fragments a
few broken pots and a few remnants of
chard logs your heap of coins and you
slowly try to build in your mind and the
mind of you know the readers of work you
are publishing some sense of what that
culture was like and your view of that
culture is in archaeology is also
multi-layered too you are bringing
together everything and this is the
great style of German follow G they
influenced me you bring everything
together economics and the history and
are in religion and literature
everything at once okay to build this
picture and you are ready for your
entire projected picture your hypothesis
to be to be smashed okay by someone who
comes after you who had had the benefit
of further excavations looking further
evidence I just wonderful history of
archaeology over the last hundred
years where we have the expansion of our
knowledge of the dynasties of Egypt and
of you know and and the recovery of
things from the marine archaeology and
it would we find your trading ships that
have gone down in a storm in the eastern
Mediterranean with all without a
treasure-house of goods on on board
which by analyzing we can you know
recreate the life of that particular
culture now I notice the students love
it they love archaeology has a sense of
mystery to it it has give them history
they love the grandeur of the great
monuments of Egypt Egypt goes over great
with anyone I mean I can't get this the
students want me to go on with each I
grow in Egypt for four years okay and
they would stay within that I think that
is the direction we have to to go in we
have to of to remove ideology from the
classroom I don't want ideology from the
right and I don't want it from the left
okay I want I want all preachers out of
the classroom and I want facts presented
real facts I back to that and timelines
again you know I do this in my in my
classes it seems so simplistic but the
students really need it I just like draw
it with whatever course I'm teaching I
just draw long time line okay I make
these big blocks on it of like 1000 year
periods going all the way back to you
know to the beginning of ancient Egypt
from Egypt to now and like this in other
words the beginning of them that I'm
dynastic period Egypt's 5000 years I
just fill in large big things here is
the Renaissance I'm painting on here is
when you know here is a Greek period the
Roman period and they're like oh wow
well that's really interesting well okay
and then if I'm talking to them about
anything I mean I'm in the Garden of
Eden you wouldn't believe what that's
about
it's not like I'm telling you people the
elite schools have no idea okay
of the way the bottom has dropped out of
public school education okay this is a
disaster I feel again you know I'm not a
church going at all I do not believe in
God however I believe that the Bible is
one of the most the richest sources of
poetry and of myth and
of wisdom in the world okay that it that
it is the foundation of a lot of our
literature and of our art and that
students who are raised without the
Bible have no way to understand
practically anything that they're seeing
when they say to or any of the great
museums of Europe they've lost the
ability to interpret art and I think
that again art and the ability to
respond to art aesthetically is one of
the most sustaining things that teachers
can give to their students and that and
that any anything that that makes
students suspicious of art or negative
to art or ironic about art is is a
disaster to them and again it defrauds
them and it's a form of you know it it
to me is evil and it is evil in the name
of a modern theories of chic posturing
by the faculty themselves very basic
things have been taken away from the
student my advice of the students is to
at least the secondary level is to take
their education back from the faculty
and simply to go to the library okay and
it realized this is a library that is
the great treasure house of knowledge at
any in any institution it survives the
faculty the faculty thank God is mortal
the library is immortal except with
Alexandria there's one fifteen minutes
left you need to go to Q&A
oh okay all right Kathy who is Kathy
where is Kathy Thank You Kathy all right
now wait a minute all the need just
quickly
oh all right let me just do a quick
thing then all right I'm just what do I
leave out here oh my god there were so
many things you know in the old days
when the immigrant era I looked at these
books in the public libraries they're
old of books are often thrown out now
but there were these speech books speech
textbooks for speech classes in public
schools during the immigrant here to
help immigrants and their children okay
to make their way in the world learn how
to speak and to hold yourself and so on
I
these are basic tools of self present
presentation self development that we
should we need to reconsider again
particularly for for in the inner-city
school so again ways of how to rise in
the world how to you know the ability to
make verbal presentations is going to be
a very very important skill for students
in their lifetime so many of these
things from the great period of public
school education I think we need to
bring back out and dust off a window I
haven't done a secondary education yet
oh dear oh wait let me get to look very
quickly here alright now I certainly
believe that in this age of mass media
we it should be required every student
needs to take a course in the history of
mass media to understand the way the
modern technologies have developed and
the way our you know our the culture
around us including that the way we get
information has been has been managed
okay by by a host of sources that who's
you know which would seem invisible in
magical and mysterious to to the young
so I think that's important however I do
not believe that mass media should be
taught with sterile enough moded
theories of the descend from the
Frankfurt School before World War Two
why in the world would American teachers
who live in the age of television rock
music imposed German theories on people
I don't know said we have our own pop
cultural theories coming out of pot
pauline kael and you know and Andy
Warhol visit our school of of pop
cultural criticism Parker Tyler the gay
critic is my particular favorite
memorial we got to get rid of this stuff
that dates from before World War two it
just absolutely nonsense now wait what
else here oh now I believe that essay
writing ok the kind of essay writing is
encouraged in prep schools and then in
the elite schools encourages glibness in
these students and in fact is
responsible for a lot of the Great
Inflation of the elite schools in
unfashionable you see in the humanities
classes for the last 25 years to test
facts oh there are no facts which is a
matter of like just putting them into
some sort of a witty witty form the
Whittier you are the more you can sort
of toss all these balls in the air
the better I think we have to realize
that literature is also about knowledge
and when we do that bring our courses
back to to learning facts rather than
just game playing and learning this kind
of like the kind of superficial whimsy I
think that the grades will fall which i
think is I'm very happy to be able to
give c's and d's at my school probably
no one's ever seen a C or D here you
know what that is
Sierra D I don't know used to be there
was a gentleman see in the old man all
right well I'm just going to have to
stop okay
all right because we are told there are
to be questions and who is going to lead
this question are you going to leave
this question period oh you are well
they look like a fairly docile crowd
never know there could be a rabbit for
structuralist among them I'll leave it
to you
[Applause]
[Music]
well there are four microphones two
below and two above and if you want to
approach them and please state your name
and affiliation and keep it short and
keep it a question
hello mrs. Walia my name is Gareth
driver on a sophomore at the college and
I'm proud to say I'm a graduate of of
Oaks High School
my mother went to Harvard in the early
60s before they had the curriculum
reforms so she was required to take a
survey course in the humanities and when
I told her that I was reading Plato's
Republic among my classes she she asked
me a couple questions about it so I was
trying to talk to it a little bit and
she wasn't really able to hold the
conversation so I asked to look at the
book she'd read for a class and it
turned out they were a four-volume
summary of philosophy from Plato to
Hegel uh and she hadn't really read the
book even though she knew when that
Radcliffe yes it was right oh right
cliff yes well rec that was kind of
isn't it kind of in the dead now no she
hadn't actually read the books even
though she knew the facts oh I wonder
there might be something more than facts
that needs to be taught well I mean I
think people should be reading the
original text of things and not
summaries I think that whoever designed
you know whatever teacher that was with
it was at fault I don't know if that was
it I I don't want to defend Radcliffe in
the early 1960s I mean husbands know
yeah oh yeah my name is Adam Soph and
I'm a sophomore at the college um I was
interested what you're saying about
education about art in like secondary
schools I mean I agree you know like the
best course I've ever taken in high
school or college was my senior art
history course but it seems to me like
your whole sort of attack on the system
today comes you know you're attacking
leftist critics and post-structuralist
obviously but wouldn't you say there's
equally a problem rooted in for example
the right wing who's attacking the
National Endowment for the Arts for
example whoa
by and large okay you're saying a lot of
things that because actually I have to
the NEA for for its you know for I mean
I've written extensively about it
actually I think the NEA has behaved
appallingly it should have been the
guardian of our in this country has made
itself that the servant of the worst
kind of PC and really angers me because
the money the money for the National
Endowment I have been going at big
$40,000 clubs to individual artists I
have even though I teach in art school I
do not believe that I believe that that
money should have been going to
supporting institutions that the public
can go to of the museums at community
arts centers of music lessons for
inner-city youth keeping the classical
music stations on the radio in the city
is now and you don't notice this in in
in Boston you have very good music here
any any real big college town is going
to have good music stations but its
Philadelphia which is a major music town
sort in the origin of a lot of all kinds
of famous musicians and jazz and soul
and rock and so on classical music is
necessary on the radio because people
who are economically impoverished have
no other access to it but that and
people come from from homes which you
know people who are here hear classical
music playing at home I have access to
it can afford $16 CDs and so on
it is tragical to another neh should
have been supporting that that's what
you're not supporting high so the NEA is
a victim of its own foolishness and I'm
not a wonderful net for a minute now
however I'm glad you mentioned the art
history thing because too often in
primary education in America what art
classes for young children are playtime
okay let's bring out your creativity
have some clay you do it that's not my
idea of an art class I'm you do it okay
look I can paint this thing like I want
the students know real art especially in
America where we don't have a tradition
of high art whereas in Europe the young
people see art all around them indeed
it's a burden to the people of Europe
it's too much the burden of the past is
very very strong to why so many of us in
America probably are more original
because we don't
feel the weight of all those antecedents
on earth but everywhere every building
that you see in the European city is in
some way you know art artistic
experiences to be in its presence we
need to have art history at the very
earliest grades now this to me is also
the way that you begin to build
tolerance for gay people right it's not
by telling them be nice to the gay
people okay by having people come in and
preach to you you know in that very
intrusive way that I think is
disrespectful to people of other who are
very traditional in their religious
beliefs people who are Hindu or a Muslim
or or Christian may believe
homosexuality is a sin and they have a
perfect right to say that and they
should be allowed to say that I'm saying
to the lesbians they have a perfect
right to say that anywhere and they
shouldn't be muzzled because of some
someone else's political ideology the
way that you build tolerance is by
exposing young children to art and
slowly over time as they learned about
artists this one was kind of odd you
have to say that they were gay because
sometimes they weren't gay they were
just odd okay there are you know sort of
like Michelangelo was gay Leonardo was
gay they were odd now if they if they
had had a sex life probably they would
have been gay but don't tell me they
were gay those guys were these crazed
man a snake isolated types different
pretty boys as apprentices but I just
look at I think from home and so I feel
that that by the history of arts by
showing the you know the history of
genius which again is on the one of
those things is out the window
in the humanities Department I happen to
believe in it there have been geniuses
in history in the sciences and in the
arts who have made enormous differences
in our culture enormous differences
powerful personalities and the more
powerful the personality the more is
appealing to young people so by showing
the lives of the artists I'm gana the
Italians okay who are on the forefront
of this it is we are the first to apply
the word genius okay to to to painters
and sculptors who worked with their
hands before that poets and traditions
and people alike wrote tragedy and so on
had had greater oppressed
and the saris live of the artist the
idea that that artists life should be
cataloged in his he is a great man
should be honored again is one of the
Italian contributions to to the world I
think that this is we've got to start
exploring this I feel art history
authentic art history also to so many
nudes in the history of art and that's
another way to sneak it all in okay all
right I think it's another way to
liberalize people's attitudes without
preaching to them mate well in there go
on about that um I just
where's the president speaking Oh what
oh my god they doing now found repair
just give your name my name is Chris
Hayes um I don't go here um lucky you I
I was just wondering what what's one
specific definite thing that legislators
or school or formers can do right now
tomorrow wake up and go to the office
and do that you would recommend to make
public schools better well number one or
everyone note we can actually not
tolerate one more moment of the
deplorable condition of the inner-city
school so every time I see billions of
dollars being sent abroad for foreign
aid every military junket that I see
every Tomahawk missile that I think
being sent off for some reason as we're
on some peacekeeping mission mix me my
blood boil okay when I think these that
these are tax dollars that should be
going to these inner-city kids we are we
have a very combustible social problem
on our hands I think that should be a
number one on a national agenda I think
you know the reclamation of physical
reclamation of the inner cities and that
that restructuring of the public schools
I think that's number one question up
here oh my name is Robert Hughes I'm a
sophomore here I'm a student in
mathematics and I was wondering what do
you think is the most important thing
for a science or mathematics student to
study in the humanities you have a
limited amount of time mm-hmm okay here
we go now this is the entire point when
people are who are majoring in any of
the other disciplines in the side
or in our history they should be able to
take a few or one or two liberal arts
courses that deal with great work of art
that truly open you know their their
imaginations to what has been
accomplished at the very top level of
history of culture and that's not what
you're being offered today I don't I
know it well not when I've gone around
to lecture at various schools I get
quite an earful okay from from the
undergraduates when I hear the stupid
things that are being taught in the in
Bini humanities courses they're
Princeton God knows I could go on about
Princeton what's happened to Princeton
there okay there's an example of a
humanities program destroyed by
affirmative action affirmative action
that benefited that will white
middle-class women okay there was like
actually pirated by white middle-class
women it is appalling when I hear what
is going on there I'm just disgusted by
it so we have got we have got to bring
the humanities back to a sense of a core
we cannot allow these like little
courses to be offered in these little
areas just to feed this the the teachers
private research interests this awful
lot of exhibitionism going on on the par
of the humanities faculties and it's
because they want to increase their own
value on the job market is become it's
an incredible fast track to to wealth
and in success or it's no longer what it
was in the 1980s but your question
really speaks to this okay it really
speaks to this it should be obvious okay
to the people who are majoring the son
in science or mathematics should be
obvious which are the more most
substantive and most useful of the
humanities courses you know then when
you in when you enter those courses
again I feel the teacher should get kind
of evangelist for the humanities every
humanities teacher should be a proponent
of an advocate of the humanities right
not someone who's like you know in this
kind of posture of detachment and just
world weariness and all knowingness and
so on God do I hate that I in it and
what a betrayal of the 1960s that is
because we are nineteen sickness our big
word was Wow that was WOW far oh that
was our big thing okay what happened
what happened to that what happened to
that you know
with the Seinfeld era okay with pre
floating detachment Oh
drives me crazy anyway I'm sorry I'm
sorry that there is not you know an
abundance of riches for you to choose
from blame this institution we'll take
two more questions you you sir
my name is Justin Porter I'm a senior at
the college first let me compliment you
on making Harvard's most shocking
rhetorician retro or Titian professor
Mansfield blush at least three times
this evening he blushed maybe four but I
want to heart back to a response you
gave a couple of seconds ago a lot of
your of your speech seems to reflect on
Allen blooms closing the American mind
and I was wondering what your thoughts
on music were particularly popular music
and how it affects kids in in primary
and secondary education well it's
interesting you mentioned Allen's loan
because I have just responded to a
question on my you know what not on my
salon column on internet s Camille but
in the the new section on education
called ivory tower just tonight's going
up online tonight a person wrote in and
asked me about Allan bloom and I respond
to that length so that there will be a
plan for tomorrow's edition presumably
and the closing of the American mind
when it came out in 1987 is I think is a
major book in American letters it's
going it's going to last blew himself
was treated outrageously and you know I
wonder whether in some way it didn't
start in his life he died a fairly young
I think was 62 so knowing that when he
died 1992 but it's not a book either I
felt particularly was clearly congenial
to me so much of it as an attack on my
generation of the 1960s he was born in
1930 and the word Lucia I certainly
support his idea of a core curriculum I
think that he is quite right about that
that that the faculty have been and
their responsibility when they said well
we're not going to run able to agree on
what a core curriculum might be and they
throw everything to the wind and there
was a new kind of relativism on campus
but I there's a kind of doer quality to
his world
mine I'm a product of the you know of
that of the swinging 60s I particularly
of London when Mary Quant and you know
Rudi Gernreich and and you know Warhol
and the Rolling Stones and the door in
the Jimi Hendrix a loud slam boy and to
Senator so I look at at this and I feel
it's very constraining the world that he
sketches even though he does make rest
some references to art to ours
he is primarily a man of the book of the
word he is a philosopher and I'm I'm
certainly you know my PhD is in English
literature and film but yet I'm very
much how many by images and by movies
and and by and by your costume and all
kinds of the choreography dance all
kinds of things don't really get into
his worldview so I find I find he's
working a little bit too limiting now
his attack on rock is very interesting I
think for him he feels that once you've
listened to rock he will become
incapable of ever appreciating classical
music again now I don't believe that I
believe that well I'm very eclectic in
my musical taste I love classical music
and I adore rock rock has been
influencing me for 40 years
in fact I teach a course at the
University of the Arts that's on trance
song lyrics that was especially designed
for the for these student musicians and
composers I find that very very
interesting to talk with students who
were actually involved in this right in
their own music how to mesh word with
with music and how do you shape a song
and the architecture of a song and so on
but anyway I do feel though that that
was a massive statement blooms book with
Allan bloom spoke now Harold Bloom was
my mentor people always mix that up in
Europe they always say think I was Elam
stone Harold Bloom was who was my
dissertation director but I think that
that's the most considerable of the
statements of the protests against the
the decline of our of the educational
system there's there's no no doubt about
it and unfortunately did get caught up
in what was going on politically in the
Reagan presidency when William Bennett
was a Secretary of Education Lynne
Cheney was the chairman of the of the
National Endowment for the Humanities
and so on so it got politicized and the
actual intellectual
all protest in it was somewhat
overlooked by up by by you know by the
very arrogant then a high liberal
faculty on the various campuses we just
refused to listen to it and now you know
I think that people need to go back to
it and realize that there was a wisdom
and experience in in that book
it's definitely book of substance thank
you for the question
are the last questions are yes thank you
my name is no I'm wife time also a
senior like Justin um correct me if I'm
wrong but what I hear you seeing on the
one hand is that you are rightfully very
concerned about fear to stick with facts
and education and a cater to particular
ideologies and attitudes on the other
hand you're very concerned about a loss
of mystery reverence and awe and you
feel like educational contexts are
appropriate venues for the creation of
those things how do you reconcile well
in my own work in my book sexual persona
for example I talked about the
Apollonian donation principles which
Nietzsche talks about but he did not
invent it came out of Plutarch actually
writing about Delfy I feel these are the
two great elements in human life the
Apollonian is rigorous and orderly is
fact-based and in the dynein is is the
mysterious part that's instinctual and
it we must develop both those faculties
and human beings I in my work I draw
untaken pagan precedence I tried to
sweep away judeo-christianity as
completely as I can and go all the way
back to Prague into a pagan ways of
seeing the world
so yes the Apollonian which is which is
the fact they start and then the dynein
which is the mystery of nature the
mystery of the universe I think those
two things are the two elements in in
each individual which education should
develop thank you for that question
[Applause]
all right
[Music]